I wasn't very old and I first saw it
maybe five or six or so it was a long
time ago but I remember it quite well
for what feels like the longest time the
whole experience of it felt like a dream
like it never really happened just an
image in my head
forgotten memory perhaps I can't
remember exactly where the place was
just what it looked like and the same
for the people there no face or name I
could say now maybe they weren't even
there
just editions by time to the memory
slowly changing the Devils in the
details but they don't matter much they
never did
what did matter was the kelpie it was
summertime and I was playing near the
Bayou not far from my grandmother's
house I had been sent there to spend the
duration of the warm season my mother
thought it'd be good to breathe fresh
humid air instead of the city smog my
summer that year was spent with my
grandmother down south she was a fiery
old lady second generation from Scotland
often she will tell me wonderful tales
of the locks and forests from her
parents homeland about all the creatures
that lived in the waters and those that
lived in the trees one of my favorites
was the silky beautiful seal woman who
could change shape at will as they
swarmed the ocean another was a Koosh go
a more ferocious beasts but also quite
interesting to me my grandmother said
they could take the form of a singing
woman and they would lure sailors into
the ocean and then drown them in the
water when they got close like sirens
the one I loved most though was the
unicorn such a majestic and mysterious
creature I liked how pure they were told
to be I had always had a desire to see
one - such as pure white coat but I knew
they weren't real they were just stories
one afternoon I went down to the bayou
to catch a fish I was very proud of
myself having made the pole from a stick
and some string my grandmother laughed
and said if I caught a fish she would
cook it for me
I became very determined to the task and
I told her I would be back before
sundown I waited at the banks of the
water legs crossed and pole in hand
it was a small bit of uncooked bacon at
the end of the line my concentration was
broken by the sound of music someone was
playing a fiddle the sound was
enchanting I looked around for the
source not finding one I tried to follow
the sound abandoned in the pole and the
bank with the line still in the water I
quietly crept along the bank walking
until I found the source of the music I
found who was playing the fiddle it was
a young man sitting on the branch of a
tree the branch hung just above the
water and the man laid against it
suspended over the mirror like surface
playing a tune - his wooden fiddle he
stopped when he saw me and smiled no
words came between us but he gestured to
move his hand to take a seat on the
mossy Bank and he continued to play the
music was wonderful when the song ended
I asked for him to play another he
nodded but only if I went further into
the water
my grandmother had been very clear with
me to keep out of the water I could not
swim at the time and she had made me
promise to stay on the bank he played
another song and when it finished he
gestured for me once again to come
closer even deeper into the water like
he was going to tell me a secret and
whisper it in my ear I shook my head I
had made a promise the young fiddler
seemed disappointed I can't quite
remember the details of his face but I
can remember he's frown he sighed and
rolled off the branch into the dark
water without a splash just a few small
ripples came from where he entered the
Bayou I never did see him leave the
water after that I went back to the
house as my grandmother called me first
I ran to the pole and saw a tiny fish at
the end of the paperclip hook
I almost told my grandmother about my
encounter with the young fiddler but I
chose not to she would just think it's
strange and say it was nonsense the next
day I went back to the Bayou banks
fishing pole in hand I said to my
grandmother that I will catch a bigger
fish I told her are to be back before
sundown
I went back to my spot and sat
cross-legged pole in hand there was a
small cut of deer on the hook i sat and
waited for the fish to bite my thoughts
trading off to my grandmother's stories
they were stopped by the sound of
laughter it was a girlish laughter light
and soft I was curious
usually the Bayou was so lonely just a
call from faraway birds in the chirp of
crickets I followed the sound leaving my
Pole on the bank and the line in the
water moving silently I walked along the
bank in the same place with the
low-hanging tree branch where I found
the source of the laughter that small
watery Grove seemed just a little
different a large gray rock sat in the
middle of the water
emerging from the deep I hadn't noticed
it before
possibly I just hadn't remembered it
from when I met the young fiddler
sitting on the rocks were three young
girls they looked a few years older than
me all of them had long dark hair that
swayed around them like thousands of
waves silk strings here in them laughs
made me happy I don't really know why I
got closer and sat in the bank and
watched them the girls were as beautiful
as the selkies in the tales my
grandmother told me they all had fair
skin that seemed to glow in the dimmed
by you light one of them met her dark
eyes of mine she gestured with a finger
towards me she wanted me to come and
play I wanted to they seemed as though
they were having so much fun up on the
rock I took off my shoes and rolled up
my pant legs I waded in up to my knees
and my feet sunk slightly into the mud
but looking down into the water I
remembered I couldn't swim
one by one they slid effortlessly into
the water and swam towards me only the
eyes are visible above the water with
their hair flowing behind them they swam
around my legs barely disturbing the
water one pulled gently at my leg
and another at my hand once again I
shook my head I could not play with them
disappointed they sighed dismal II and
let go of my hand and left slipping away
like the water they swam in I didn't
want them to go I almost swam in after
them but I heard my grandmother calling
my name I went to get my pole a small
fryer was at the end of the line I
almost told my grandmother about the
sake girls but I chose not to I felt
like they were mine somehow like a
secret that only I knew the following
day I set out again I was going to get a
bigger fish today
I had to this was my last day in the
Bayou I was going home the next day I
told my grandmother I'd be back before
sundown
and went to the bank to fish I gazed out
into the dark still water it seemed
almost dead lovely but dead a metallic
blue dragonfly landed on the water took
a sip and flew off
I watched it as it went my attention was
then turned to the most unusual noise
hooves and a neigh there were no horses
in the Bayou so I started to wonder I
put my paw down on the bank and left the
line to sit in the water
I followed the sounds of a brain horse
yet again I came to the same place the
willow hung low the tree branch sat
above the water and the rock was empty
of any selkie girls standing by the tree
on a small island bank in the middle of
the water was a unicorn it didn't have a
horn much to my disappointment but there
it was a pure white horse it poured at
the ground of its longford whose its
Mane was elegant and shiny it seemed to
glow just like the silky girl's skin and
the young man's fiddle strings it was
beautiful
even if it wasn't a unicorn as the Bayou
girls are not selkies it looked towards
me and waved his head up and down it was
calling me without hesitation
I got into the water I didn't even take
off my shoes I stood knee-deep the white
horse trotted into the water and began
to swim to me I was hoping it will play
with me on the banks or at least the
shallows it stopped though just a little
further out from where I was I couldn't
stand there but then again it was much
bigger than me I was sure the water
couldn't be that deep over there
it looked towards its back offering me a
riot in my excitement I forgot about my
grandmother's words and went deeper into
the water up to my chest
then my shoulders the water felt
suffocating as it went higher and higher
I felt my lungs were being crushed under
the pressure I held my hand to the white
horse it was still just out of reach I
took another step and the water was to
my chin my fingers brushed over its
silky main water weeds had collected in
the main giving it green flecks here and
there I went to touch it again this time
though it felt more sticky like tape or
glue looking down into the water the
white horse had lost its glow it seemed
more grey darkening the further it went
down until it was almost black maybe it
was just the water my foot slipped I
went down under the water opening my
eyes in panic I was horrified at what I
saw in front of me well the white horses
belly and legs would have been I only
saw smooth black decaying flesh and the
black legs fused together in a slowly
Fanning tail it was like something out
of a nightmare I immediately step back
my move been slowed by the water I
turned around and my head broke the
surface as I reached the shallows I
scrambled onto the bank and looks back
the white horse had gone I felt a relief
although I deeply missed the white horse
where had it gone I heard my grandmother
call my name and in my soaked muddy
clothes I ran back to my fishing pole a
large catfish was at the end of the hook
I left both of them where they were and
hurried back to my grandmother's house
I told my grandmother about the white
horse I did this time I left that the
selkie girls in the young Fiddler's for
my story and I did not mention the
nature of me falling into the water but
I asked about the white horse she told
me a tale about a kelpy it was a water
demon that often took the shape of a
beautiful white horse amongst other
things
such a handsome man playing a violin or
a young maiden it would offer a ride to
anyone willing then take them into the
water and drown them nothing would ever
be found of them that night I forced
myself to go back I needed to see if it
was real by the light of my torch I
followed the path I had taken as I
searched for the source of the sound
but off the hours of surgeon I couldn't
find it no green willows no tree branch
and no rock I went back home the next
day happy to be away he had desperate to
come back but I never did until recently
my grandmother had died a month before
she had only visited once since the last
time I spent the summer with her I
traveled back down to the bayou back to
her home to pack up her things and sell
the house I had almost forgotten most
three days down at the banks of the
Bayou the whole summer had been a blur
that year but going there brought the
memories back for so long I had
dismissed it as a dream or some dull
event of meat and other people a man
playing an instrument some girls
swimming in the water and an animal in
the bank a deer perhaps or white goat
that had lost its way nothing too out of
the ordinary for the south maybe the
white horse was just in my imagination
but to reassure myself of the childhood
nonsense I decided to go and just take
one little look that morning I'll be
back before sundown I found my old
fishing spot my pole was still there
somehow as if I had just left it I even
found the fresh carcass of the catfish
that I had left there years before I
tossed it into the water curious then I
heard music fiddle music and laughter
and the sound of a horse
I followed the sound and I found the
same place the place of the Willows in
the low-hanging tree branch and the rock
and the opposite bank with the tree once
I got there though all the music and
laugh that was gone the tree limb sat
empty over the water and the rock was
isolated and alone
and the opposite bank was the white
horse the kelpie it shook his head and
gestured for me to come over once again
something seemed strange out of place
but against my better judgment I took
off my shoes and stepped into the water
faintly I could hear hissing and a quiet
screeching noise it sounded like he was
coming from the water I ignored the
sounds and went deep into the Bayou
finally it was getting too deep to stand
as I kicked off the bottom my foot hit
something sharp I don't think had bled
though so I continued across the water
without a thought I couldn't shake the
feeling that something was under me
swimmin maybe even multiple some things
I climbed onto the bank as I got close
to kelpy kneeled it was offering me a
ride I remember what my grandmother had
said about these offered riots I took a
box knife from my back pocket and held
it behind my back I stepped closer and
hesitantly put my arm on the Magnificent
Beast the white fur was soft and felt
like water in my hands I told myself
that I shouldn't I had one of those
feelings that you get when going into a
dark tunnel or alley you know it could
be dangerous and it most likely is but
you still go a sheep the knife and sat
atop that white horse it stood and
prompt in a circle I laughed
oh how I'd wish I had done this years
ago looking up I saw the young fiddler
laying on the low hanging tree branch he
plucked a string and began to play he
had a handsome face with shaggy blond
hair under a hat his clothing looked old
like it was from the Wild West the three
by who soaked Eagles came out of the
water
and lay atop the rock laughing and
brushing the water weeds out of their
hair with their fingers I noticed their
faces this time soft delicate features
with shining dark eyes and smiling
mouths they all seemed so happy I
started to feel the same a large grin
was
on my face it wasn't long before that
was replaced with a feeling of sickness
I had a deep ache in my stomach I was
scared but of what I try to lift my hand
from the horse's neck I wanted to get
off I wanted to swim to the other bank
and run away from this place my hands
wouldn't move I tried to pull myself off
with the hand that was free but it was
stuck like it had been glued I watched
in horror as the white horses coat began
to gray before my eyes becoming darker
and darker finally it became an oily
black it turned its head towards me no
longer was it the beautiful creature
that I had seen across the bank it was a
monster the kelpie its eyes were blue
and clouded and I could see its jagged
teeth through its decay and mouth a long
greenish black tongue lapped out of its
jaws the kelpie skin started to become a
sticky black goo engulfed in my hand and
surrounded my legs I called for help
from the young fiddler and the sulky
girls it was like they didn't notice me
shouting at them when they did finally
look at me I realized that things
weren't as they seemed no longer were
the sulky girls beautiful in Yong their
skin was green and rotting one of them
even had a missing eye they gaze lazily
at me with tilted heads as if they were
frowning at me in disappointment from
they're attracted lips and bare teeth
and my fateful decision to ride the
kelpie I turned to the young fiddler his
clothes were half torn and he's face
peeled away he plucked a few sad notes
before his skin began to bubble and
turned black
the silky ghost did the same slowly they
all dissolved bone and flesh into the
same black goo that the kelpie was made
of gradually they dipped into the water
and dissipated like ink becoming
underwater smoke as soon as they were
gone the kelpie lept into the water with
me on its back as it drove deeper I
tried to pull away the melting black
kelpy skin was slowly crawling up my
legs and chest I was running out of air
I grabbed the box color from my pocket
and cut the selkies decaying flesh it
screeched and looked at me with dead
eyes I saw my own reflection in them it
was angry it was in pain I slashed again
it bit me just inches from my face I had
managed to free my legs and as I
attempted to cut away the black flesh
around my arm and hand the kelpie jerked
and changed direction causing the box
cutter to dig deeply into my arm
silently screaming I watched in horror
as the loss of my heir escaped to the
surface I cut at the kelpie again and I
was free had a small glimpse I noticed
aloud at the bottom of the Bayou there
were bones down there human bones in
that short look I counted at least four
skulls the kelpie screamed and swam off
into the dark water as I pulled myself
to the surface I gasped and coughed as
my face was touched by the warm humid
Bayou air I looked around nothing was
moving dead silent I noticed a small
ripple a few meters away it got closer
and closer then it disappeared only a
second and passed before I felt
something grabbed my ankle and yanked me
back down under the water I was being
dragged back down the kelpie seemed
incessant that I would never make it
back to the banks I opened my eyes to
see myself face the face of the kelpie
its black mane flowed around me below me
the silky gills were grasping at my
ankles I jabbed the knife forward into
the kelpies eyes it screamed again such
an inhuman noise that he made my ears so
as if they were about to bleed I no
longer felt hands crossed open up my
legs the grip of my ankle was gone the
kelpie screaming swam away the
box-cutter still lodged in its I quickly
paddling my way to the bank I hope that
the kelpie would not come back for
revenge as I reached the shallows I
slowly walked forward holding my freely
bleeding arm blood dripped into the
water from my fingertips I crawled up
onto the mossy bank and laid on my back
for a moment to catch my breath
my legs were covered in mud up to my
knees blackening the ends of my rolled
up jeans I looked around
it was nearly night somehow the Sun was
gone and the first few stars began to
shine in the darkening sky the quiet and
beautiful Lagoon had changed in
appearance just like the creatures that
inhabited it the rock was mossy
crumbling and cracked the low-hanging
tree branch was broken and sticking out
of the water
all of the willow trees are dead their
leaves decane upon the ground in clumps
the rest of the trees look sickly as
well nothing here was healthy or alive
my hand touched something smooth looking
behind me I saw the remnants of a Polish
fiddle
it looked broken untouched for years
further away I saw the remnants of three
colorful beach towels they were just
threads now the skeletons of fish around
every discarded item looking closer into
the weeds I noticed more dozens of
things left behind by those who rode the
kelpie I never did go back to the Bayou
I sold my grandmother's house to a happy
family from out State New York I warned
them not to get too close to the waters
they might be Gators as I got into my
car and started to drive away I watched
as the boy talked his mother's sleeve
I'm going to the bayou
I'll just have a look I'll be back
before sundown my heart began to ache
for the boy's mother yes I told myself
I'm sure he'll be back before sundown